welcome back to the stronger by science
podcast this is your host eric Trexler
and for today's episode we have a very
special interview with dr. Gabrielle
fund arrow doctor fund arrow is an
expert in gut health so while we had her
attention we asked her a ton of
questions about what gut health is
dietary fiber intake artificial
sweeteners prebiotic and probiotic
supplements and much much more as always
thank you for listening to the stronger
by science podcast and we hope you enjoy
the interview so obviously we reached
out to talk to you and as everyone in
Fitness knows you've got a
specialization specifically pertaining
to gut health but for anyone who's not
aware of your background do you mind
giving us a little a little profile of
who you are and what your background is
yeah absolutely
so yeah dr. Gabriela and arrow my PhD is
from the department of human nutrition
foods and exercise at Virginia Tech and
I was actually studying in a skeletal
muscle physiology and biochemistry lab
and as it turns out sort of a series of
serendipitous events that seemed kind of
unlucky at the time but have turned out
fairly well led me to study the
interactions between the microbiome and
peripheral metabolism and specifically
looking at the potential for probiotic
supplementation to be protective against
some of the dilatory effects of high-fat
feeding in skeletal muscle metabolism
and so I worked with rodents there was
also subsequent study in humans
spoiler alert probiotics are not really
that helpful oh well that was really the
only question so I guess we I mean we
can kind of pack it in but thanks for
coming by
yeah yeah good you know got it all done
in five minutes so I thanks thanks for
the listeners and everything yeah we try
to be efficient so now most if not all
of your work you're doing with
Renaissance period ization is that right
I mean I would say a majority I also
have my own kind of little side busy and
consultations under vitamin PhD
nutrition and that
for folks who were I would say sort of a
niche group whereas with RP I'm doing
email coaching and speaking to folks who
are you know largely gen-pop anywhere
from recreational exercisers to
competitive athletes plenty of
individuals who want to learn or you
know their own coaching or those who are
in the medical field and then the people
that I work with one on one through V
PhD those folks generally have some form
of gastrointestinal distress or
discomfort and/or are interested in more
sort of non macro non-tracking long term
weight management approaches and so what
I found is that quite often individuals
who have some you know GI issues not
necessarily that it has to be a disease
state but it's often concurrent with
sort of restrictive eating patterns and
so they may have gotten something like a
food sensitivity test because they have
GI issues and now they're not sure what
they can eat or not and so I work with
them to help educate them and help them
kind of regain control of their diet and
their GI symptoms and so that's that's
my maybe 25 percent of what I do and and
then the other 75 is with RP awesome and
so you've got the academic background
you've got the coaching going on and you
also you've also competed yourself as
well yeah yeah so I don't make any
claims about being like a super
competitor or anything or any type of
athlete I usually just kind of dabble
for a while and see what I like so I
have dabbled in physique I did a
physique competition in 2015 some Jiu
Jitsu quite a bit of trail running back
when I was more of an endurance
exerciser and in recent years shifted to
powerlifting so I did oh I would say
like 5 meats and you know about over a
little over a year which is a lot but I
kind of just wanted to you know see what
it was about and have fun with it and
yes
that's most recent dabbling has been in
that awesome now you were talking about
your coaching and you said a lot of the
clients you work with have many of them
have some kind of issue related to gut
health and gut health is becoming a bit
of a buzzword in the evidence-based
Fitness community you hear a lot of
people talking about it and because of
your expertise I've got a whole list of
questions for you but the first question
is kind of a vague one but what exactly
is gut health we see a lot of people
talk about it but it's rarely like
really defined I think I was hoping you
were gonna be able to tell me that
because this is the first and best
fitness podcast and there's actually no
definition for gut health so gosh I
guess I should probably leave now
because that's the only that's why I was
here but yeah so so gut health is one of
those kind of big buzzword marketing
terms and and that is actually it's kind
of tongue-in-cheek but that's something
that I point out that we don't have one
profile of a healthy gut in terms of the
microbes that are present we do we're
starting to identify sort of a core
human microbiota so that means a group
of microbes that seem to be present in
all human gastrointestinal tract so we
have these these guys in common we have
co-evolved with them sometimes people
call them old friends or or these sort
of commensal bacteria that are neither
you know necessarily positive or
negative they just happen to be sort of
human specific so we have an idea that
those guys should probably be present
and we can also look at sort of the
relative abundance of microbes that
would be considered to be pathogenic or
disease-causing versus those that are
considered to be beneficial or at least
neutral and ideally we have a larger
relative abundance of those that are
beneficial or neutral but we haven't
been able to establish causative link
between even the pathogenic strains and
various diseases with which they might
be associated so when we sequence the
micro biomes of individuals around the
world we find that all of the healthy
controls may cluster together by region
but we don't see as much clustering
comparing region to region so for
example individuals in Korea healthy
controls will look different from the
healthy controls that are in the US and
the largest variability that we see the
greatest explanation for why two people
might look different in terms of
microbial profile it's like a
fingerprint it's just enter individual
variability so when we're looking at the
microbiome we can't really say that
there's just one healthy profile of
course when we look at sort of the
anatomy and the physiology of the gut we
can say that gut health would be sort of
the it may be the absence of disease or
the absence of a pathology and that's a
little bit easier to define so if
someone is you know free of an
inflammatory bowel disease and you know
they don't have any sort of
uncomfortable GI symptoms that would be
quote unquote good gut health but some
of the foods that we would eat that
would be great for the microbiota are
highly fermentable and that can cause
things like gas and bloating and GI
distress and so that means there's a
disconnect between what could be
considered a healthy or functional
microbiome or microbiota versus what is
you know perceived by humans to be
healthy so yeah it's just one of those
kind of buzz words that can mean a lot
of different things and so people can
use in various ways yes I feel like it
sounds like it's one of those things
that the definition can be hard to pin
down to try to get a universal
definition but I would imagine it's not
that nebulous for people that come to
you for help because they say I've got a
gut issue because I have symptoms so
yeah yeah kind of view it functionally
as in absence of symptoms I guess yeah
to some extent and I think also
expectations about what what are what is
actual symptom ology versus you know
what is just hey individuals will
sometimes experience gas and bloating
and some distension because some foods
are highly fermentable and we are filled
with
couple pounds of living organisms that
are producing gas and other substances
is they're fermenting so I think some of
that is just about education and then
also you know personal thresholds for
what is a invasive level of gas and
bloating and distension so it might not
be that they actually have this the
presence of a disease but you know maybe
poor gut health to them it's just that
they feel bloated and they're you don't
have comfortable bowel movements and
then that's something that can be
addressed even though they're it's not
necessarily that there's anything wrong
with their gut or with the microbiome
and then it's just a dietary
intervention which is pretty often the
case yeah I'm shooting from the hip here
so if I'm wrong please please do feel
free to correct me but it also seems as
if there's a pretty significant when it
comes to gut symptom ology a pretty
significant psychosomatic influence as
well is that correct yeah that actually
does appear to be the case that stress
management is actually one really
effective intervention for the symptoms
of irritable bowel syndrome especially
so if individuals have chronic diarrhea
or chronic constipation and other
potential diseases have been ruled out
quite often they'll receive a diagnosis
of IBS and some of the really effective
interventions are things like
mindfulness and yoga and cognitive
behavioral therapy and that sometimes
these can be you know more effective
than traditional interventions like a
pharmaceutical so it's you know mine I
think
mindset probably plays a significant
role because it can modify how we
process stress and you know stress is
going to be a constant for all of us but
there is some rodent data illustrating
that chronically elevated cortisol as
induced by a stressful environment like
a really aggressive cage mate can
actually cause some changes to the
microbiota now do we know the clinical
outcomes of that no we can't say that
that is then a cause a causative factor
in developing IBS
but just that it's some evidence that
the cortisol may be impacting the gut in
some way and people will often see it
increases in symptoms when they're under
a great deal of stress so you picked
quite an area to specialize in because
it sounds like you pretty much have your
hands full whenever you have kind of a
new issue that comes up it could be so
multifaceted so I have some questions
about how certain things affect the gut
microbiome but before we get there you
talked a little bit about how we can't
necessarily say here is the template for
you know the perfect human microbiome
but I have seen some literature breaking
it down into what they call enterotypes
yep
but I have also seen literature pushing
back against some of the Enduro type
classification so these enterotypes are
these legitimate ways to classify the
gut microbiome and if so what are they
so when taro types are kind of like
somatic i p-- so you know when people
say I I'm an endomorph mesomorph
ectomorph that there are predominant
taxa that have specific sort of
behaviors or have specific preferences
for nutrients in the diet and so early
research started to characterize these
as being more prep atella dominant more
Bacteroides dominant and there are a
couple other sort of sub classifications
as well looking into more ROS birria and
so they the idea was that if an
individual's diet is higher in complex
carbohydrates they'll be more primitive
dominant if it's higher in animal
proteins is going to be mad more
Bacteroides dominant now part of the
reason that we're seeing some pushback
there is that we aren't actually seeing
these very consistently in the
literature so for example looking at the
some of the dietary extremes like in
Ekans so with vegans obviously they're
not ingesting any animal products and
their diets are generally going to be
high in complex carbohydrates but in
some cases the microbiomes of vegans
actually have elevated levels of
Bacteroides compared to omnivorous
controls so it's just that I think what
happens is what it's it's impacted by
the level of resolution with which we're
sequencing the gut so how far down are
we actually able to look into these
taxonomic groups if the very early
classification I think the first example
of enterotypes would be comparing the
for Mickey D's versus the Bacteroides
groups now that's like comparing
vertebrates versus invertebrates but
early on there was this theory that for
Mickey D's dominant individuals would be
more prone to obesity because many of
those for Mickey D's they just found
that it as it happened back then many
people with obesity seem to have higher
levels of fur Mickey D's but there are
plenty of beneficial groups of bacteria
within that file out like lactobacilli
so we can't say that you know one group
is necessarily going to be obesogenic or
predispose us to being lean it's just
that that was because it's such a kind
of a blurry resolution it's easy to
group bacteria in that way that that's
something that started to emerge but we
have to realize that the effects of
these bacteria are not just species
specific but even subspecies specific
and in most cases were just not looking
with that level of resolution with that
level of specificity when were
sequencing microbiomes
and we're also looking at fecal data in
most cases versus the samples that would
be you know all along the
gastrointestinal tract and looking at
things like lumen versus mucous so I
think we were working with sort of the
patterns that were emerging based on the
technology that we were using then
and then and now as technology is
improving and we're getting or
large-scale trials we're able to see
that those things are not emerging
consistently enough for us to be able to
I think characterize enterotypes with
any level of certainty perfect so yeah I
mean this this whole landscape of
research I was talking about on the
podcast the other day you know it
there's so much unresolved within the
literature still in terms of how we do
useful groupings and categorizations
that are actually robust enough to feel
good about exactly
but yeah so at this point I feel like
we've got a good primer on gut health in
the microbiome now I want to ask you
about certain things that we can do that
may or may not affect our gut microbiome
so one of the things I hear very
consistently is that fiber intake is a
huge determinant of what our microbiome
looks like is that true to say I would
agree with that with the looking at it
in terms of sort of a hierarchy though
so in terms of the context or batli
against what backdrop are we comparing
fiber intake so again it comes down to
that issue of resolution so you can kind
of think of it as like if you're looking
down from a helicopter onto a forest
below and we can see the tops of the
trees and we might be able to identify
that there are a few different types of
trees present but we night now we might
not be able to see all of the other
organisms that are beneath the trees and
even if we get down a little bit closer
we might be able to see some shapes and
say okay I can see that there are deer
down there but which species of deer are
there and so when we're looking at the
effects of fiber on the gut if we're
zoomed out really far and we're
comparing that against the backdrop of
just inter-individual variability it's
going to be a really small effect even
though it will have a large effect on
some specific taxa or some specific
groups of microbes as a whole our
current longitudinal data is showing
even comparing dietary extremes that
anywhere from about 60 to 80 percent of
the microbes present stay
much unchanged for most of our lives so
while we can say that yes fiber probably
has a pretty significant impact in you
know compared to something like a
supplement overall the impact might
still be a little bit smaller than we
would hope but that being said you know
we can look at the absence of fiber
again sort of a dietary extreme and this
is something that's been repeated in
rodents at least if we feed a diet that
is completely devoid of fiber and or low
in polysaccharides in general so other
types of carbohydrate that we actually
see some changes in the microbiome that
may be associated with a loss of the
protective mucus layer coming covering
the intestinal cells now that can
certainly be regarded as a negative
outcome with probably some pretty
significant clinical implications and
then we also can look at you know in
humans fiber supplementation does seem
to have some benefits in terms of easing
constipation depending on the type of
fiber and also seems to play a role in
things like appetite regulation and
insulin sensitivity so there are
potentially some positive outcomes for
fiber supplementation does that mean
that the changes in the microbiome are
causative we don't know that yet it
could be that those changes are
happening concurrently but one is not
causing the other okay now the the other
end of this or the other kind of food
intake question that I see a lot
pertains to meat so you had taught me
viously about vegan diets and how that
might affect the microbiome so do it
sounds like fiber there's some
Association there but maybe not as big
as people have hyped it up to be what
about meat it is there is it is meat
intake associated with any particularly
good or bad effects on the microbiome I
think this depends also on you know
if we're looking at just kind of a
prudent diet because a lot of the
studies thus far that have been looking
at dietary effects on the microbiome are
using dietary extremes so we're
comparing vegans to omnivores or even
vegans to an all meat and cheese diet so
this was something that was done several
years ago they put for five days they
had two groups one was a plant-based
diet one was an animal-based meat and
cheese diet now the folks that's
transitioned to the plant-based diet it
probably wasn't too terribly different
from their baseline diet so they really
didn't see any meaningful changes in the
microbiome whereas individuals who
shifted to the meat and cheese diet saw
some significant changes from baseline
once they return to the previous diet
than their microbiomes bounced back to
their previous states as well so what we
often see is in we do see fairly
consistently increases in Bacteroides
that doesn't necessarily mean that they
are only associated with more meat more
animal proteins but they seem to be a
pretty dynamic taxa
so they can adapt to changes in nutrient
availability
whereas bifida bacteria seem to be a
little bit more they're a bit finicky a
little bit needy of fermentable
carbohydrates so when we reduce the
levels of fermentable carbohydrates in
the diet like if we're in a low fodmap
diet or a gluten-free diet then we do
see fairly consistently reductions in
levels of bifidobacteria so what
sometimes happens is that when we're
comparing diets and we and we you know
compare a higher protein to a lower
protein diet that it's not just
necessarily the protein that's changing
or you know if we're looking at just you
know cross-sectional like looking at two
groups that have always eaten this type
of diet that we also have to keep in
mind that the other macro nutrient
levels will change as well so there are
some there's some studies that have
shown with regression regression
analyses that increase protein intake
mate might lead to reduced microbial
diversity and then others that have
shown that it's associated with
increased microbial diversity but again
that's just looking at protein you don't
know what the sources of the protein
might actually be there have there's one
there's a recent analysis that came out
looking at you know comparing vegans
versus vegetarians versus omnivores and
they actually noted that in vegans who
sometimes ate red meat which i thought
was really funny they had similar you
know positive health outcomes to people
who were a strict vegan so does you know
is including meat in any way problematic
no but I would venture to guess that if
we have a diet that is only animal meat
that could be problematic not
necessarily just because of the meat but
because of the lack of fiber and microbe
accessible carbohydrates yeah and so
when you say an increase in microbial
diversity is it safe to assume that
that's a generally favorable outcome
maybe
actually it was framed that way but I
want to make sure it's always it's not
yes so it's not always going to be a
good thing and this is another so there
have been a couple interesting sort of I
think op-ed pieces that have come out
looking at diversity and so the term
diversity and the term dysbiosis and you
know what they actually mean and are
they always good so diversity just is
looking at the richness and evenness of
species so we're looking at how many
species are present and then what are
the relative distributions of those
species now you could potentially have a
change in diversity an increase in
diversity and have an increase in
pathogenic strains of bacteria so that's
not necessarily gonna be a good thing we
have increased diversity there because
of you know increased numbers of species
that we can measure and you know perhaps
changes in relative abundance but yeah
it doesn't necessarily mean
it's a good change or a bad Cheng's it's
just a change in the number and/or
relative abundance of species between
two samples yeah but that's the most
frustrating part of working through some
of this literature as a non expert in
this specific niche is that you'll see
these studies that say like here's a
thing that seemed to have a change and
you're like good or bad and they're like
well it's different exactly yeah and
it's because these microbes their
behavior really is context dependent so
they might not even express any
virulence factors there might be you
know the presence of pathogenic bacteria
might not be a problem at all and and
you know we expect to see them in the
gut we expect to see strains that could
cause disease we just need them to be at
low enough numbers that when they're
doing something called quorum sensing
they're sort of put sending out a census
to see how many of themselves are out
there that it's low enough that they
don't decide to express virulence
factors they don't decide to act in a
pathogenic way they just sort of hang
out and you know the other commensal or
beneficial bacteria are keeping them in
check and so overall we're disease-free
even though they might actually be
present and so when we see a change in
diversity if we do see that you know
their numbers are increasing that could
potentially lead to pathogenicity that
you know wasn't so much of a concern
before and then in other cases we can
have bacteria that may because they're
interacting with each other they could
be collaborating so there could be like
a symbiotic effect they could be
competing and so they may cause issues
in one individual and not in another
depending on the backdrop of the other
microbes that are present as well and
there was one I can't remember the name
of the bacteria now but I have it posted
somewhere on my Instagram but it was
like within a couple days they had two
different I think it was a myth antigen
they had two different papers published
on this same guy and it was like one was
woohoo he's helping protect us against
these and the other one was like oh he's
increasing virulence factors of this
other one and it was just like you
what's that saying from Batman you live
long enough you need their diet hero or
live long enough to see yourself become
the villain that's kind of what happens
yeah so correct me if I'm wrong here my
kind of mid question summary or mid
interview summary here it seems good to
have at least some fiber in the diet for
the gut microbiome and you can probably
make it work
whether you're on a strictly plant-based
or omnivorous diet do those sound fair
oh absolutely yes beautiful okay so now
another thing that I've seen in the
literature linked to the microbiome
artificial sweeteners what do we know
about artificial sweeteners and the
microbiome not as much as the internet
thinks that we know actually shots fired
shots fired
that's good worldstar in here yeah
Instagram thinks that the artificial
sweeteners will just kill your entire
microbiome and what the data actually
shows is that a we actually have
relatively few human studies looking at
artificial sweeteners and the microbiome
of those we have some that are a
relatively low participant number and in
one case that the one people like to
point out all the time we actually
didn't have a control group for some of
the data that is most compelling so I'll
start with the the one that people are
shocked to hear but we actually have I
want to say two or three human trials
illustrating that aspartame does not
seem to have any effect at all either on
the microbiota or the function of the
gut so it doesn't cause any changes and
in the production of that hormones and
the bacteria are completely unfazed and
doesn't have any clinical outcomes so
aspartame is you know if you want to go
for the one that we have pretty you know
at least we have some confirmatory
trials it's showing it's not doing
anything now the others that you know we
either have confessed
it's still emerging data or some data
that might want unity we might want to
be considerate of looking into saccharin
and sucralose these do seem to interact
with them with the microbiota to some
extent or impact it in some way and so
what's kind of required there is that
you know the this whatever we're
ingesting it has to you know ideally
reach the large intestine where the
majority of the microbiota are present
and then also interact with them in some
way and if it's something that's like
just an inert chemical that they don't
want anything to do with and it can't
influence them then we don't really have
to worry about it now the ones that
we've seen may have some effect would be
saccharine and Circulo s-- still minimal
in humans and that's at really high
levels of intake so upwards of the ADI
so the acceptable daily intake which is
something like 150 pound person anywhere
from about thirteen to seventeen cans of
soda a day or 30-plus packets in a day
so if you're ingesting at that level
then it's something to consider
obviously the dose is what you know we
really need to keep that in mind so
second we have to look at you know how
many people are actually going to be
affected when the one study that really
Illustrated that there's a potential for
impact to the microbiome and insulin
sensitivity what they really did was
they took a subset of the participants
there was about seven participants whose
microbiome changed with ingestion of
saccharin and from there they they took
some fecal samples and provided them to
my so they took people samples from the
humans implanted them into mice and they
saw that the mice Illustrated some
insulin resistance and so from there
they determined that the changes to the
microbiome would then have led to
insulin resistance but again when we're
looking at that you know it is our seven
individuals really enough for us to be
able to extract
blade that to all humans and then from
there looking at a subset of those
individuals feces in rodent models is
that something that we can safely
extrapolate to humans I would say you
know probably not I am pretty
conservative on what we can apply to
humans and then you know looking at the
actual health outcomes when we are
replacing something like a sugar
sweetened beverage with a non-nutritive
beverage that does have really clear
positive health outcomes
so when were you know concerned about
the minutiae of artificial sweeteners on
the gut well we just don't have the data
to be to really support the opinion that
there's going to kill the microbiome I
think people are probably extrapolating
from cell culture data so if you want to
see a huge magnitude of effect on
anything
put it on cells bunches of them will die
or if you want to you know do it in
rodents and so there's plenty of rodent
data illustrating that artificial
sweeteners can have some deleterious
effects but it's a super physiological
doses there's just no way that we as
humans would be able to ingest that
level of artificial sweetener now when
we're looking at the the non-nutritive
not artificial but sugar alcohols those
do seem to have pretty significant
effects on the gut but in a more
positive way because they're prebiotic
now people will usually feel bloated and
gassy because they're highly fermentable
except for our wrists at all but you
know if you want to have something
that's super prebiotic well there you go
sugar alcohols have you seen the
absolutely legendary Amazon review for
sugarfree gummy bears okay that happens
for everyone else listening to this just
google it was on review sugarfree gummy
bears it is one of the best pieces of
content on the entire internet just
insofar as it relates to consuming Oh
too high of levels of sugar alcohols oh
yeah that's like if you if you don't
want to go for a traditional
ah Skippy prep instead sugarfree gummy
bears that is all you need
literally like nothing will touch the
sides you will elevate above the toilet
seat and then like there you go that's
your that's your new year's resolution
colon cleanse detox right oh man it was
ridiculous though cuz what wasn't it
like a five-pound bag of sugarfree gummy
bears and purse it was like first of all
I'd have to make sure you guys know this
don't eat them all in one sitting it's
like who the [ __ ] is five pound of
sugar-free gummy bears in one sitting I
found your problem seriously you know
the dose again is is relevant they're
like you could probably deal with but I
don't know you know what the funny thing
is like one of the things that I look
for like a carefully in products is
chicory root fiber or inulin it's
there's nothing toxic about it except
your farts after you eat it it cause the
absolute worst gasp some people are like
oh it's a fiber it's natural it's so
good for you and I'm like good luck with
that the abdominal pain you're about to
experience is probably not your appendix
is probably just horrible gasps yeah so
the things you don't want to like binge
eat if you're like you know what I want
to binge eat responsibly and you're
thinking like those two ingredients that
Gabrielle just mentioned or like
sugarfree gummy bears sugar-free
chocolate these are things that should
not be binge eating no no absolutely not
and it's like the England it does not
take much like there are some well-known
vegan cookies on the market and they
have changed their recipe I used to be
able to eat these I would actually eat
them like before I was gonna go lifter
I'd bring him to meats and whatnot
because they were delicious
and settled well and were you know
relatively low enough in fat high in
carbs they plenty of you know sugar a
little bit of protein um but yeah I had
half of one a few months ago and I was
like am i dying is this the end of me
because I didn't know that they had
added chicory root to their in green
and it does not take much it really
doesn't take much of a bad or sorbitol
so if you see something like on the
packaging it's like excess consumption
may have a laxative effect by excess or
excessive they probably mean like maybe
two pieces instead of one and it's
insane
yeah that's those dangerous it kind of
reminded me of the reviews of olestra
from back in the day what wasn't that
the like the non-digestible fad that
they wanted to kind of be like the same
thing as artificial sweeteners
yeah but though I think the potato chips
were like Wow potato chips
Wow I think I just pooped my pants
mm-hmm yeah it was exactly the same
stuff like theoretically it's I feel
like that was one of the Dumber things
because the way it was marketed it was
like hey there's this stuff that tastes
like fat it will give you the same
mouthfeel as fat it does all of the
things you would want fat to do in your
cooking but it's not digestible so you
don't you know it's virtually no
calories so people saw that and they're
like oh sweet so if I want to binge on
an entire family sized bag of potato
chips ultimately I'm just getting the
starch from that like none of the fat
that would otherwise come with it but
that's exactly not how someone would
want to consume olestra products because
if you're not digesting it it's gonna
come out the other end in massive
quantities and so a really good idea in
theory but I think olestra products were
pulled from the shelves after maybe a
year tops just because consumers
couldn't use them responsibly and would
end up complaining like oh this made me
[ __ ] like no other product I have ever
come across mm-hmm I bet there's a
chemist somewhere who who is like an
artist who just made their masterpiece
like 200 years ahead of its time and
it's like you idiots just can't
appreciate my creation why would you
possibly think you should eat the whole
bag because like olestra that was the
thing everybody ate way too much of it
everyone's like whoever invented this as
an idiot and it's just like I I'm pretty
sure it's gone right like I haven't seen
it in ages no sane I mean it is kind of
a
bad idea when you sit and think about it
a little more though because like any
significant amount of it would give
people pretty significant GI symptoms
and a lot of diarrhea and so like if you
were it would be useful for saving the
calories if you were only going to
consume a little bit of fat but if it's
if it's only gonna be a little bit
unless you're like a bodybuilder deep in
prep it's probably not gonna really
negatively impact you like if you're
replacing enough fat from your diet with
olestra to actually have a meaningful
impact on total calories consumed then
it's going to destroy your toilet so
it's kind of like there's it didn't seem
like there was any actual meaningful
application for it because once you use
enough for it to actually matter
you know physique and total energy
intake wise like good luck to your
bathroom yeah it's it's certainly not a
feasible standalone weight loss
intervention yeah and sort of an
interesting like social experiment too
because people were aware of the risks
and like they still push the envelope
they still were like well let me see how
much I can eat maybe I can handle half
of a bag of potato chips like you're
really willing to take that risk like
that is hedonic eating at its finest
these chips taste so good I am okay with
potentially pooping myself alright so I
think that's the fourth time we've
talked about pooping our pants so I'm
gonna bring things back toward toward
artificial sweeteners now I had to look
into this literature that for the
December issue of mass that's coming out
soon
there's a new study looking at sucralose
I was really stunned when I found
exactly what you were mentioning there
is very minimal human data pertaining to
the effects of several artificial
sweeteners on the gut microbiome
especially sucralose the cupboard is
very bare you know like you mentioned
there's plenty of I wouldn't say plenty
but there's some stuff for aspartame
some for saccharin but sucralose we need
to get to work
we need to start doing those studies
yeah and you know I think because you
roses is molecularly similar to sucrose
I am curious as to you know the
potential magnitude of effect there you
know if it could interact with the
microbiota I think you know potentially
that might have the the I don't know it
might it might have the greatest
potential is what I'm saying not to you
know [ __ ] on super Louis or anything
like that
but yeah I mean what we have so far is
really looking what we have a couple of
rodent studies but again when we're
looking at doses that are just
inconceivable by human standards it's
not super helpful to us
yeah now when you were talking about
sugar alcohols you talked about how many
of them are fermentable mm-hmm so that
fermented foods is basically a whole
class of foods that that I would assume
have pretty notable impacts on the gut
microbiome as a whole is that right you
know it's kind of funny it's another
kind of similar situation to the
artificial sweeteners where we espouse
all of these potential effects but the
human literature is really lacking so
what we have probably enough evidence
now to say that it probably doesn't have
a huge impact would be looking at
fermented dairy not to say that there's
no impact it's just that fermented dairy
doesn't seem to be appreciably different
from non fermented dairy in terms of
potential beneficial health outcomes so
things like reduced all cause mortality
increased or improved body composition
reduced risk of cardiovascular disease
so these are all great health outcomes
but it seems like you could get it if
you have regular milk or if you have to
fear that the effect on the actual
microbiome is pretty insignificant and
pretty minimal it might affect just a
couple taxa or you might see slight
enrichment in some of the strains of
probiotic bacteria that as a whole when
we're comparing that against thousands
of species what effect will we really
see by changing like a couple subspecies
especially when we consider how stable
the microbiome is as a whole there was
actually just a something of a position
sand put out recently kind of stating
this saying that you know as a whole the
microbiome is actually really stable and
we don't know what the magnitude effect
of effect is for a lot of these
interventions and that it might actually
be really hard to identify anything
happening at all in a meaningful way or
what the clinical outcomes are so you
know fermented dairy up maybe but don't
when we look at the effects of you know
kombucha there was sort of a
tongue-in-cheek systematic review put
out last year with one study in it and
that's that's you know that the authors
knew they knew what they were doing
they're like haha systematic review
here's one study and it's actually not
even a study it's just like an op-ed
piece about the potentials for kombucha
effects on on the on the gut and on
humans which is you know even sort of a
separate outcome and then if we look at
you know the other other sources of
fermented foods so just not not just
kombucha but if we're looking at you
know fermented vegetables like kimchi
sauerkraut is sometimes fermented but
people kind of confuse like pickled with
fermented so not all pickles are going
to be you know or fermented food they
might be just pickled with vinegar or
fermented protein sources so there are
some fermented meats fermented fruits
grains so at overall it seems like they
the the most the greatest benefit that
we see is that during the process of
fermentation almost always we're
reducing the levels of those fermentable
fibers or fermentable carbohydrates
which makes those foods more digestible
to us so we don't get as many GI
symptoms of like gas and bloating when
we eat them so that's nice and you know
dairy that's one way that we can produce
the lactose content but in terms of
meaningful change to the microbiome
then any clinical outcomes that might be
a result of that really there's pretty
much nothing out there so it's kind of I
find it a little bit funny that like
there are people really supporting the
ingestion of these fermented foods and
even in place of probiotic
supplementation no probiotic
supplementation is one area that has
shown there are some there are some
microbes that have quite a few
confirmatory trials showing that they
are effective for reducing symptoms of
various disease states so that's
promising and we know that we can you
know get we can get those probiotics
ideally with a specific number of CF use
or colony forming units but something
that we're getting it from a food source
we have no idea how many viable bacteria
are actually in that food source and
really you know the with with certainty
what strains are present and the effects
of those bacteria are going to be
strains specific so it's a little bit of
a gamble to just you know rely on a
probiotic containing food to get your
probiotics in my opinion yeah and that
actually is the next thing I wanted to
ask about after fermented foods is you
see a lot of ley press articles talking
about prebiotic and probiotic foods
could you give us a rundown of what what
the difference is and what some of those
are yeah so the prebiotic would be the
food source for the microbes and those
are going to be another word would be
microbe accessible carbohydrates they
are quite often fibers but not always so
the the key for these to be considered
prebiotic is that they would have to be
able to feed microbes that means that
they have to get to the large intestine
so if it's a carbohydrate that we have
the ability to digest and then absorb
that's really not going to be as strong
of a prebiotic as one that we can't
digest and so it will pass through to
the large intestine where those bacteria
can then ferment it and produce your gas
or short chain fatty-acids now the
probiotics are the actual microbes
themselves that when ingested might
confer some benefit to the host now
previous definitions specified that they
had to be living that might not actually
be the case it may be that we could have
nonliving microorganisms that may still
have the potential to influence the
microbiome in some way that confers a
benefit to the host and so like the
spore forming probiotics are a thing now
because they might they don't
necessarily have to be alive but they
produce spores that can then give rise
to viable bacteria and then there's a
new term post biotics which are products
that are produced by bacteria that put
then again confer some benefit to the
host interesting so you talked a little
bit about how certain probiotic
supplements might be able to induce some
changes
what about prebiotic and probiotic foods
specifically are you more favorable do
you have a more favorable view of
supplements when when it's you know a
well-made supplement um well in terms of
prebiotics we really don't have to
supplement with prebiotics because those
fibers are going to be present in whole
grains fruits vegetables legumes
even you know if you're if you're
lactose intolerant and you can't break
down the lactose that could be
considered prebiotic also but it's
usually pretty unpleasant so most people
don't want to eat that if they can't
digest it and then you know clear it out
of the small intestine but those you
don't really like I said you don't have
to supplement if you eat a diet that is
high in microbe accessible carbohydrates
high in fiber then you're getting the
prebiotics that you need and that's what
we find is that in groups of individuals
who eat very high fiber diets and diets
that are high in complex carbohydrates
they have a great abundance of microbial
diversity and those microbes are in
anisha's that are very good at
processing those carbohydrates so
they're they're fermenters where
as the individuals who have less lower
levels of 5 or lower levels of
carbohydrate in the diet that they will
see a comparatively reduced levels of
diversity and that's even you know where
we're looking at like the hodza is one
group they might be eating 100 to 150
grams of fiber per day as compared to
individuals in the US who average about
15 to 19 grams of fiber per day so we
can see some pretty appreciable
differences between those two groups
without any need for supplementation
it's just that their diets are very high
in fiber when we look at the the
application of probiotics I do think
that it is probably more prudent to go
for a supplement that has you know
something like the equivalent of a USP
label so us pharmacopoeia that's one
that just tests for purity and potency
it's not anything about safety or
efficacy it's just that what's on the
label is actually what you're getting
and you know that might be different in
other parts of the world but some way to
determine and it's difficult but so way
to determine that you are actually
getting the number of CF views that are
on the label because while there's no
single amount that we are concern you
get in each day if you're going to be
supplementing it looks like it's
anywhere from between 1 to 5 billion CIF
use 1 to 2 times a day anywhere from 1
to you know many many weeks because we
don't have the systematic way that we
administer these probiotics you know to
every population across all studies so
the best we can do is just look at ok
this seems to be effective most
effective at these doses for generally a
longer duration of time and then these
strains that are used their effects seem
to be pretty specific to a specific
disease state so for example s blue Rd
is one that I have mentioned quite often
because there's a great deal of evidence
support
its efficacy in reducing symptoms of
antibiotic or travelers associated
diarrhea one that seems to be super
specific to pediatrics is lactobacillus
rhamnosus GG doesn't really seem to help
with adult diarrhea but it does seem to
help with pediatric diarrhea and so
there are other strains that might be
beneficial for reducing symptoms of IBS
or IBD but then they're not really
helpful with antibiotic associated
diarrhea so if we're doing something
like just you know eating just drinking
kombucha and eating kimchi we don't know
that we're getting those specific
strains of bacteria or that we're
getting them at sufficient doses to
actually cause some relief so in that
case even though most of the time I very
much food first I do think that it's
important that we you know utilize those
well supported probiotic supplements in
the appropriate applications I'm glad
you mentioned antibiotic associated
diarrhea because that's kind of where
I'd like to go next
no we've been talking about things that
could possibly like increase the health
and diversity of the microbiome so
shifting gears one of the things that
I've heard from a lot of sources which I
don't know how true or not true it is is
that taking antibiotics you know for
some sort of bacterial disease or
infection and just absolutely wreak
havoc on the gut microbiome so is that
the case and if it is the case how long
would that take to recover after a
course of antibiotics and what are some
things that people could do to recover
yeah this is actually another area that
it's hard to get where it's hard to get
consistent data because there are so
many different types of antibiotics and
so many different populations and you
know if someone's taking an antibiotic
for something like a gastrointestinal
infection well do we necessarily want
them to return to their previous
microbial profile maybe not because it
might not have been great to start out
with
whereas if individuals are taking it you
know
for a cold or there was a recent study
looking at children in Malawi and they
take fairly long courses of antibiotics
to help prevent infection and and I want
to say that it was as if from Iceland so
in I've seen some studies that have
shown that as if from ice and doesn't
really have much of an effect on the
microbiome you know in otherwise healthy
adults whereas something that's really
strong like vancomycin will absolutely
wreak havoc that's made to knock out
c-diff so yeah it's gonna be a really
gnarly antibiotic so I think it's really
gonna come down to you know what if we
do have in something like Anantara type
so the initial so the baseline microbial
profile will probably impact how the
type of effect that the antibiotic might
have on the microbiome and then what
happens after we come off of the
antibiotic well that is also dependent
upon your baseline microbiome ideally
you have one that is fairly resilient
dynamic and that is often associated
with diversity as well so you might
bounce back really quickly if you're on
you know something that's a pretty weak
relatively speaking antibiotic for a
short period of time but if you're on
something strong for a long period of
time or even in these Malawi and
children they're on as if from ice and
for a long period of time then there are
appreciable reductions in bacterial
diversity again what does that actually
mean we have to kind of look more like
the clinical outcomes well yeah so a
person might end up with antibiotic
associated diarrhea that could be
problematic they may end up with a
another infection so see diff is often
comes after antibiotic administration
because we have a loss of diversity and
so it can grow and flourish and then
there was a one really interesting study
that came out last year that looked at
some of the you know comparing
interventions after antibiotic
administration what's the best thing to
do do we want to take a probiotic do we
want to
nothing and get back to normal or do we
want to do an autologous fecal
transplant so we take our own fecal
sample from before the antibiotic when
we add you know healthy microbiota and
then take that during or after
administration of antibiotic to help
sort of replenish those native microbes
and interestingly they found that the
most rapid reestablishment of the
microbiota came from the people who did
the autologous fecal transplant which
makes sense because those are your
that's your personal sort of entourage
of microbes they have adapted to your
gut and to your lifestyle and if you
take those guys and put them back into
their native environment and go back to
your normal way of living then they
probably would thrive second best was
doing nothing just going back to your
normal lifestyle and diet probably
eating you know microbe accessible
carbohydrates it took them a couple
weeks to get back to baseline whereas
with the autologous people transplant I
want to say it was one within a couple
days now the people who took the
probiotic supplement it was a
lactobacillus containing probiotic
supplement they actually experienced
what the author's considered to be a
form of dysbiosis because although they
did see fecal enrichment of the of the
lactobacilli they didn't see those they
didn't see a rebound of the native
microbiome it was almost as though the
lactobacilli for perhaps out competing
some of the other microbes that were at
a lower level after administration of
the antibiotic but there there was
another study that came out also that
year that looked at some individuals
actually experiencing what they
considered to be probiotic resistance so
they ingested probiotics but they didn't
take so they actually just went in one
end and out the other and they looked at
that that court seemed to correlate with
diversity of the cecum which is where
the small intestine meets the large
intestine is sort of the hotbed of
bacterial proliferation and so perhaps
so you know if you have a diverse
microbiome and you kind of get back to
normal after you take your antibiotics
taking a probiotic might not actually do
anything at all if you already have sort
of a robust microbial profile so again
it's really gonna be person specific and
we don't have enough data I think in
either direction to say with certainty
one thing will happen after after
antibiotics
I gotcha and so I'm glad in the answer
to that question you mentioned fecal
transplants as well that's my other
question so I think that people just
just from the name alone find the
general idea distasteful but there's
some Hardy wild rodent research on fecal
transplants especially in terms of its
possible abilities to treat obesity and
other related health issues is there
similar research to that in humans
what is it found and just how would a
fecal transplant be accomplished for the
people listening so sadly we we actually
had there are some small pilot studies
administering fecal transplants for the
treatment of obesity and thus far it
looks like they may see some
improvements in metabolic markers but no
actual improvement in obesity so this is
in contrast to rodent data in rodents we
can pretty reliably induce obesity with
a fecal transplant or we can go in the
other direction and we can actually make
mice pretty resistant to obesity if we
raise them germ-free or with specific
strains of bacteria but that does not
appear to be the case in humans so thus
far fecal transplant doesn't look like
it's going to be an effective
intervention for obesity or obesity
related diseases and they've looked at
people transplants and other things too
like mood disorders and again that it's
really not promising they're the most
effective application of people
transplants would be for treatment of
seed if it's really thus far the most
effective treatment proceeded so fecal
transplants can be done in a couple
different ways so they can actually
encapsulate the the fecal sample from a
healthy donor they process it they
screen it to make sure that there aren't
any pathogens hanging out in there that
could potentially be problematic and
that an individual could ingest those
they can also do it in the form of an
enema the potential issue with the enema
is that it might not get far enough up
the gastrointestinal tract but again
since the majority of our microbiome is
hanging out in the colon in the large
intestine especially distally that might
still be okay even if it doesn't get you
know way far up in there
so yeah either way and they usually are
going to you know ask for a donor who
might know the person sometimes people
are a little bit more comfortable with
that
but yeah I you know I think in the u.s.
testing has been you know clinical
testing has been at least put on hold
because they did recently have a death
due to fecal transplant there's a person
who was immunocompromised and they
received a sample that had I think a
pathogenic ecoli and they ended up
passing away from that unfortunately so
there are definitely risks to fecal
transplants Italy not something that
people want to do in their own home not
even an autologous fecal transplant but
you know there are potentially some
interesting applications for it make
sense to me please don't
I've heard of anecdotally a one gasps
gasps dry rot one gastroenterologist who
actually did make their own little fecal
transplant slurry in their home don't
reuse that blender oh that's so gross no
III was following along this line around
people have weird hobbies
I was following this line of research
and you know I was really excited about
it thought I'd had a lot of promise and
yeah the suspension of all those ongoing
trials was such a yeah I mean it's
horrible at somebody lost their life
it's it's horrible that they had to
suspend these trials because it was
looking so promising at the time so
unfortunately looks like we're gonna
have to wait and see if they can
implement more safety measures before
those resumes yeah yeah as far as I'm
aware you know I and I think you know
when they were using them in the c-diff
trials like it was even unethical for
them not to treat the people who - who
were in the control group like it was
that effective and within just a couple
of days I mean almost instantaneous so
even if that is the only application I
think that's still really exciting
because you know that's a severe that's
what one of the most common
hospital-associated infections and I
know actually a couple of people who had
c-diff and so so dangerous especially
for elderly individuals so like yeah
even if we're not gonna be able to you
know quote-unquote
like you know treat or cure prevent
obesity with it I still think that it's
worthwhile to continue on with you know
treatment proceeded definitely now a
Gabrielle we want to be very respectful
of your time we've had you for about an
hour already and throughout that hour I
mean this was a action-packed interview
lots of questions lots of really
interesting answers a lot of times we're
just sitting here twiddling our thumbs
going like so how's your bench feeling
these days but this was this was a
whirlwind so because we've covered so
much I think it would be beneficial
before we wrap things up to have a bit
of a summary you know we talked a little
bit about fiber meat and protein
artificial sweeteners no we talked about
some sugar alcohols are fermentable and
have some positive impacts but that
doesn't mean that every fermentable food
is going to have an impact can you wait
and what was even more interesting is
when we started out the interview you
had a somewhat pessimistic comment about
probiotic supplements but then some kind
of less pessimistic stuff later on with
certain contexts right
so I think it'd be really helpful to
have a little bit of a summary statement
to wrap it up of if someone is it is
interested in doing everything in their
power to support you know a good
quote/unquote healthy microbiome what
can they actually do and what might they
want to actually avoid yeah so I would
say when we're looking at lifestyle
interventions we would start with diet
make sure that they're eating a diet
that is high in microbe accessible
carbohydrates generally speaking those
are fibers from whole grains fruits
vegetables and legumes so that's one of
the dietary aspects physical activity is
also associated with diversity and
beneficial short-chain fatty acid
production so exercise regularly not too
much in terms of you know when we talked
in the beginning about mindset stress
management and sleep management also
seem to play a role in you know helping
to maintain a healthy body weight which
is also associated with increased or
sustained microbial diversity and quote
unquote gut health so it's not super
sexy but you know eat your fruits and
vegetables and whole grains
exercise regularly try to find ways to
manage and process stress like
meditation spending time with loved ones
and you know trying to find happiness
day to day you know those are the types
of things I always say you know my PhD
research was in nitrates and I always
say try to eat a bunch of nitrates from
plants and if it doesn't work then the
side effect is now you have a great diet
anyway you know if you got a bunch oh
you got yes so it sounds like for this
it's like hey work out sometimes not too
much eat some healthy plants try not to
be stressed all the time maybe you have
a beautiful microbiome after that but in
any case you're healthy and happy yeah
exactly like can we just make these
things cool even if they don't have a
huge effect on the microbiome there's
still just really good things to do yeah
and when it comes to you know everybody
wants to talk
supplements we talked about probiotics
it sounds like most people probably
don't need one but if you are gonna go
that route there are some some certain
clinical outcomes that might be altered
but you got to make sure you get the
right dose the right strains and a high
quality you know certified third party
certified kind of product yes exactly
awesome now Gabrielle if you have the
time for it one question we asked people
a lot of people to come on because you
work with some clients we're always
interested when we talk to somebody from
the evidence-based perspective are there
any things you do either in your own
training or things you instruct clients
to do that are not fully supported by
the evidence yet but you just are
totally in on it like you totally
believe in it oh man that one is tough
for me because I try to be like really
really careful about all of my
recommendations I would say probably the
most out-there thing that I've
recommended was you know after ruling
out all of the basics I was like hey you
know I've seen some interesting stuff on
like peppermint oil and oregano oil just
try those see if you like them if not I
won't be offended but that was it I
can't even say that I like whole
wholeheartedly really believed in it so
I'll have to I'll think about that if I
think about anything weird that I do I
will shoot you guys a message and let
you know perfect and what were they
doing with the oil just like a food
additive yeah yeah just eating it
because peppermint oil seems to be
helpful with like nausea and that's it's
actually from like medical nutrition
therapy they actually mention that so I
still was like okay I found this in a
text book I don't feel so so bad about
it but you know I think to some extent
like everything that we say about the
microbiome thus far is like maybe
lacking evidence a little bit so we're
all just kind of doing our best so maybe
you know if I want to be really
skeptical and critical of myself like
everything that I say yeah I mean what
are you supposed to do when were
we're looking at a body of literature
that's developing in real time yeah yep
exactly
awesome well honestly Greg can attest to
this because he can see the outline we
got through about half of our questions
I had a whole other line of questions
all about FODMAPs one of these domes
yeah one of these days we're gonna have
to twist your arm get you back on the
show and ask the other half of the
questions I think we could do a whole
additional hour oh for sure but we won't
put you through that today we sincerely
appreciate your time now if our
listeners want to stay in touch with you
or stay up-to-date with what you're
doing where can they find you online
yeah so I have a web site that I don't
update often enough but I have a bunch
of podcast there they want to listen
it's vitamin PhD nutrition com they can
also reach out to me there if they're
interested in coaching I do a little Q&A
with them just to determine what type of
coaching would be the best fit for them
if they want to check me out on
Instagram and Facebook and vitamin PhD
if they want to look me up on
Renaissance period ization dot-com they
can just check out Gabriella and arrow
RP strength put that into Google and
I'll pop up I'll pop up there perfect
everybody out there make sure you stay
in touch with dr. Gabriella fund arrow
she is excellent hopefully we'll be able
to get her back on a later date thank
you so much for joining us thank you
thanks for listening to the stronger by
science podcast now Greg and I are not
experts in medicine or health or really
anything else for that matter so before
you make any changes to your diet and
exercise habits make sure you check with
a doctor or another health care
professional if you enjoyed this podcast
and you'd like to support it visit
stronger by science com2 check out the
products and services that we offer
thanks for listening and we'll see you
next time
[Music]
[Music]
you
[Music]
you